when you think they were about to make
space history haley arsenau and cyan
procter looked remarkably relaxed so too
jared isaacman the billionaire who paid
spacex to make this happen and chris
cembroski the first all-civilian crew to
orbit the earth
five months of training had brought them
here non-professional astronauts ready
to blast off
[Applause]
[Music]
into the night sky of florida it went
without a hitch
it was a spectacular show for those
watching across a huge area witnessing
with the world a new dawn in the space
race
they will orbit for three days traveling
at 17 000 miles per hour and 360 miles
up realizing a dream for the billionaire
not with them the reason i started
spacex was to get humanity tomorrow it
is elon musk's company that's enabled a
story being documented in a netflix
series and with the aim of raising
millions for a children's cancer
hospital
these are significant times in this new
space race first richard branson
and then jeff bezos flying to the edge
of space in craft their millions built
experts say the spacex launch is a game
changer in commercial space travel
they're going higher
they're in orbital
space they're they're in orbit around
the earth
they're not minutes they're days uh
where they're gonna be there they have
actual
um mission objectives that they're
trying to achieve um and so i think it
you know it's an order of magnitude uh
more of a challenge to be able to do an
orbital flight jared isaacman named this
mission inspiration with the hospital
massacred along for a zero gravity ride
it is as much about making a difference
as making history greg milam sky news